he got very apocalyptic and he teased
that more Biden will mean World War III
now remember Trump's been predicting
World War III if Hillary were to have
gotten elected in 2016 he's been
predicting World War III during Biden's
first term hasn't happened he's just
always predicting World War III but then
he really unleashes on Joe Biden they
say Trump was right about everything
well
I'm not predicting World War III but I
will say this we're very close and
they're only talking about nuclear
weapons on top of it all Biden is the
most corrupt president in American
history and that's not even close nobody
can believe what's going on with again
no retribution whatsoever with such a
calamitous and failed presidency it is
almost inconceivable that Biden would
even think of running for re-election
you know what happened in the last
election yeah Biden won they cheated and
they rigged the election